قوه الانزال الجويه الروسيه استهداف انظمه
رادار اوكرانيه بطائره مسيره انتحاريه
روسيه الصنع من طراز لانسات ونشرت صورا
على موقع تيليجرام قالت انها للحظه
الاستهداف الذي تم في مقاطعه خرسون
في المقابل افاد الجيش الاوكراني بان
القوات الروسيه قصفت مناطق سيطره في خرسون
اكثر من 40 مره خلال الساعات الماضيه كما
يعرضنا الجيش الاوكراني واستمرار القصف
الروسي على مقاطعه ميكو لايفروليه
ومناطق السيطره القوات الاوكرانيه في
دمياط ولوغاز وقالت قياده عمليات الجنوب
في القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
تسحب بعض وحداتها القتاليه من بعض المناطق
على طول الضفه الشرقيه لنهر دينيرو الى
خطوط القتال الخلفيه واشاره لان هذه
الخطوه تتزامن مع استمرار القصف
الاوكرانيه على مواقع القوات الروسيه في
المنطقه ومع قصف متبادل عند ضفتين النهر
هذا وقالت وزاره الاوكرانيا للقوات
الروسيه استطاعت ان تؤمن لنفسها موطئه قدم
حسب تعبيرها في مدينه بخموت شرقيه
اوكرانيا اضافت ان معارك تدور الان في
المدينه بين الجيش الاوكراني وقوات ضفاجنر
والجيش الروسي بجانب الاخر وجاء في بيان
الوزاره ان القوات الروسيه حققت تقدما
وصفته بالبسيط في الجهه الشرقيه من
المدينه وانها تتقدم باتجاه الاحياء
السكنيه فيها
ينضموا ليله من الكرامه ترسم مراسل
الجزيره عمر الحاج عمر مرحبا بك معنا اذا
هنالك معارك تدور
وتقدم ولكن وزاره الدفاع الروس الاوكرانيه
كانت تقول انها ان القوات الروسيه استطاعت
ان تؤمن موطئه قدم لها في بخموت شرقيه
اوكرانيه ما المعلومات المتوفره عن هذه
المعركه الدائره الان
نعم محمد يبدو ان وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
وجدت نفسها مجبره على الحديث بتفاصيل اكبر
عن ما يدور وهذا التصريح بالمناسبه
يتسقوا مع ما جاء عبر صفحات محليه هنا
ومراقبين ومواقع في التليجرام تؤكد ان
القوات الروسيه
احرز التقدما في هذه المنطقه حديثه وزاره
الدفاع اليوم يتحدث يشير الى وجود
قتال شوارع داخل احياء المدينه اضافه الى
موقع القدم هذا او نقطه الارتكاز هذه التي
تتحدث عنها وهي غالبا في الاحياء الشرقيه
حيث تدور اعلى في بين الجانبين مره اخرى
بالنسبه لمتابعتنا لاحداث ضخم تستطيع
القول ان هناك تراجعا ملحوضا خلال
الاسابيع سته او الثمانيه المنصمه همم في
هذه المنطقه بعد ان بعد ان كان الحديث عن
معارك في مشارف المدينه وفي مناطق تبعد
اكثر من سته الى ثمانيه كيلومترات في بعض
المناطق عن مركز المدينه الارض تتحدث عن
معارك وسط احياء المدينه في حديث الوزاره
ايضا قالت ان هناك تقدما للقوات الروسيه
باتجاه الاحياء السكنيه فيها وكذلك هناك
محور اخر من همم مدينه سوري دار القريبه
منها من بخمد في اتجاه الشمال الشرقي هناك
ايضا حديث عن تقدم تقدم للقوات الروسيه في
هذه المنطقه من مصادرنا ايضا كان هناك
حديث عن سحب لبعض الوحدات همم الاوكرانيه
من تبكي على المنطقه وحديث عن الاخلاق بعض
النقاط الطبيه وهذا اجراء يتخذ في حال
اقتراب الخطر من هذه همم عن مناطق هذا لا
ينفي ان القوات الاوكرانيه مستمره في
الدفاع عن هذه المنطقه وان كان هناك بعض
همم السحب للقطاعات العسكريه يعزي الى
تبديلا في المناوباته ربما لاعاده التدخير
واصلاح العربات والمدفعيه هناك ولكن
القوات الاوكرانيه تؤكد انها تصدر عشرات
من الهجمات التي تشنها القوات الروسيه في
ذلك المحور وانها صامده في هذه المنطقه
ولا عل زياره زيننسكي يوم امس السريه
والغير هو اعلن عنها جاءت لشد عزمها هؤلاء
المقاتلين في المنطقه التي وصفها زنسكي
بانها اكثر النقاط سخونه على امتداد
الجبهه المتسعه على اكثر من 13 كلم ايضا
بلدات اخرى في هذه المنطقه في في اقليم
دامبرز وتحديدا في مقاطعه شهدت ايضا همم
هجمات المتبادله بين الجانبين والقوات
الاوكرانيه قالت انها تصدق لمحاولات روسيه
ساعات للاستعاده مناطقه سيطرت عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه في وقت ساب على محور
كريمينا اسفلتوضا هذا ايضا ياتي بعد
تصريحات اللي حاكم مقاطعه الاوكراني قال
فيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه الان باتت على
بعدي بضع كيلومترات فقط من مدينه اسباتوبا
هذه هذه المعركه التي بدات بها وشرع بها
قبل حوالي شهرين الان عقب استرجاع القوات
الاوكرانيه من مدينه
تدفع الى تلك المنطقه وان الهدف القادم
هذا لا يشعر رسميا ولكن في الاوساط هنا
مدينه تكون الهدف القادم للقوات
الاوكرانيه يستدل على ذلك من انجازات
العسكريه التي دفعت الى ذلك المحور اضافه
الى تعزيزات عسكريه
سحبت من مناطق وايضا
هي اللي توضع وتعزز الخطوط الدفاعيه في
تلك المنطقه اخيرا اعلن حاكم مقاطعه ان
يسكن اوكرانيا عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص وقد
وجرح ثمانيه اخرين في قصف على مختلف المدن
والبادات التي ما تزال خاطئه لسيطره الجيش
الاوكراني هنا في المقاطعه